when we walked into these office I saw
you on on the live TV talking about
illegal immigrants voting in DC and I
thought to myself how did something like
that become partisan right how is it
that there are issues that are so
obvious a big Corporation a
multinational corporation with
billionaire foreign investors at the
time Elon Musk now was taken over and we
can make an argument about that but at
the time you had foreign investors and
foreign interests involved in a
multinational corporation that was
suppressing the speech of not just
conservatives though mostly
conservatives but even some anti-war
leftists got caught up in this yet they
are completely like no no no who cares
who cares everybody nothing to see here
and I'm just confused as to how that's a
left or right issue I mean I get it it
benefits their party right and the
narrative that they've been pushing as
well I mean look they are for uh wide
open borders uh that's why they've done
nothing to secure Southern border that's
why we're seeing nearly five million
people come into our country illegally
that we know of that that doesn't even
count the unknown godaways that we have
no idea who they are what they're
bringing into our country uh and so this
is a part of their party platform at
this point and so of course they want
them to vote they're inviting them in
they're allowing them to come in and
they're promising them a free health
care free uh free college a free of free
education uh free lawyers free cell
phones any anything else you want and
they're really treating our
um our country to like an Oprah Winfrey
Show and now they're saying you get a
vote too and this should not be a
partisan issue this should be something
that we all unite and say no only
American citizens can vote in United
States elections you know what I find uh
I definitely want to go back to the the
immigration thing too but in terms of
like the Twitter stuff we've we've
invited often many people on this show
who are more left-leaning and only a
very very small number of them actually
come on but there's one thing that's
consistent every time they do they don't
know what they're talking about and I
mean that with all due respect I think
the the most well-read individual we've
had on the show is vosh I'm not sure if
you're familiar with them he's a
YouTuber he's a socialist guy and
there's a lot he didn't know but there
was a lot he didn't know and I can
respect that I just think he's wrong on
you know on his opinions socialism Etc
but we had people on who I asked them
about Ukraine I asked them about uh
issues at the border and they literally
don't know what's going on you ask them
what Remember When Donald Trump said
coyotes are coming across the borders
yes I do remember that the media made
fun of them because they didn't they
thought he was talking about animals
babies yes no how do you how do you
debate someone in Congress how do you
pass a bill when you say hey coyotes are
bad and they go who animals right
because most of this is a facade you
have it's 25 year old staffers give you
your talking points you go down you read
them at the mic and and then you leave
when you're done and you vote the way
your party tells you how how you're
wrecked a lot of members don't talk
about the legislation that they're
voting on before they vote on it they go
down there and say is this a yes or no
how's the party voting and and really
it's just a numbers game you have the
majority you get it passed and now I I
do think that the way that we have
changed the way Congress operates
um that that did kind of kind of help
that a little bit and and members have
to pay attention to what they're doing
and even the party has to pay attention
to what we are wanting because they've
seen that any five members at any time
can take down a bill can take down a
rule and so they have to pay attention
more and have more communication and
dialogue are you a Ron Paul fan
uh yeah I'm I I'm curious about that I
feel like
you know when I was younger
and I started learning about I started
learning more about Congress and
politics Ron Paul was getting very very
popular you know end of the 2000s and
it's because he's very libertarian guy
he talks about personal responsibility
and things like that and that that said
a lot to me my the point I made at the
time was look you know I may not agree
with him on some of his more
conservative viewpoints and religious
viewpoints but then he comes and says
yeah but I'll leave you alone right I'm
like okay you know yeah government off
my back well yeah and obviously Rand
Paul's doing a great job and then Thomas
Massey I mean he came to Congress and he
picked up a lot of Ron Paul's bills
um when he came here
um uh so he he's someone who said this
guy's doing it right I want to introduce
the legislation he was introducing and I
mean Thomas Massey I mean he's more
libertarian leaning
um than most members here and so he's a
wonderful Ally to have he and I co-chair
the Second Amendment caucus together
um but you know he he wants to limit the
federal government limit spending and uh
and and make sure Americans are still
free so let's go back we'll go back to
the Twitter stuff because I don't want
to go the reason I brought up Ron Paul
was because the beginning of this big
social media push we saw that Ron Paul
Revolution Love Revolution thing and I
kind of feel like
many members of Congress today that we
like Freedom caucus types or the the
people who stood up against the
establishment who you know refused to
vote for Kevin McCarthy we had a good
laugh about that it seems like
a lot of this may have been inspired by
that time by that you know Ron Paul
Revolution so it got me thinking about
that with social media today and the
manipulation of big Tech and the
censorship of ideas when we have people
on the show and they don't know what's
what's going on what we're talking about
right like this is the problem AOC goes
up before uh these Executives and
outright says this was a 20 what did you
call it a 24-hour mistake or something
on Twitter that doesn't matter and we're
wasting public resources
she said that Libs of tick tock spread
lies about the Boston Children's
Hospital providing hysterectomies
however on their own website there was a
video or I should say this there's a
video of a woman from the Boston
Children's Hospital explaining what a
hysterectomy is and they they say on
their website that uh or it's been
reportedly as people have been sharing
they uh provided hysterectomies to
adolescents now AOC doesn't know that or
she's lying uh I guess I'll ask you do
you think she's lying or do you think
she just doesn't know I think she's
saying what she was told to say
I mean it's as simple as that so whether
both whether that yeah whether it's an
outright lie or doesn't want to believe
the truth doesn't want to hear something
else this is what she has heard and that
is what she is regurgitating
man
uh can you hear me Chad nope you're not
coming through
you're you're just yep or you can pull
the chair up and we can swing the mic
over
people at a time uh that's the plan so
maybe so there's but yeah so there's no
audio coming through when you talk but
uh I guess we'll just keep going unless
you want to pull the chair
so uh what I can hear Ian talking but I
can see on this on the monitor they are
not going into YouTube the the sound
board is not delivering their
microphones to the computer so one
option is to you uh I I know exactly
what the problem is but there's no way
to fix it in real time it is it's it's
uh an issue
it's an issue we've dealt with with new
computers before where you have to
change a stereo mono setting or
something like this because there's two
channels but the board is
the board is only delivering one of its
channels to the computer which is why
we're not getting audio from the other
other microphones so it is what it is I
don't think we'll be able to fix it so
we'll just you know we'll hang out we'll
do what we can Ian we can we can have
you come and sit over here we'll throw
the microphone when you can but uh yeah
so so you know back to the the Twitter
stuff because I don't want to keep
wasting time talking about the fact that
our audio is not working it is what it
is uh
it feels one thing that we've talked
about in the show is cultural Decay you
know the the dark Direction this country
has headed if we can't solve this but
the way I've described it is
if you if you have a uh a person who has
become hypoxic right that the low oxygen
in the brain they can't think straight
they will not be able to write
themselves to save themselves so that's
why when you're on an airplane they say
put on your own oxygen mask before the
person next to you if half of our
country is effectively hypoxic due to
bad information lies and fake news from
the media
so they're not thinking clearly but
they're still voting right how is this
country supposed to write itself when
one lobe has been you know starved of
oxygen yes that's why it is so important
for us to have these hearings and
investigations look we don't have
um all we we don't have the Senate we
don't have the white house but we do
have the house we have oversight
um capabilities so we can begin to
expose this truth expose the mainstream
media expose big Tech and what they have
been doing and how they have been lying
to the American people what they've been
covering up the lull
um that has been created by the
narrative that they push um by by the
rhetoric
um that they allow and then by by the
information that they suppress so that's
why we are doing this in oversight so we
can get that truth out to the American
people because so many people do just
listen to what they're told on TV on on
Twitter on social media and move on with
their day uh so it's so important for
people to know the truth was hidden from
you
on purpose
it's it's such a challenge every day to
try and convince someone they're being
lied to when they don't want to believe
they're being lied to you know so no one
wants to believe they're being lied to
yeah you want to think that you have
control of your life that that people
are trustworthy that uh you can engage
in these conversations and and watch the
news and it be accurate and factual and
go on with your day but I mean the truth
is if you if you watch the news you're
you're misinformed and if you don't
you're uninformed yup think about it
ideologically when I mentioned you know
when we were talking about the
non-citizens and illegal immigrants
voting it's not just in DC I mean New
York uh has been various parts of New
York have been talking about it various
parts of California
that to me shows there is a
I don't know it feels like the ship
we're on has hit the uh has hit the
iceberg the Titanic hit the iceberg and
it's sinking you cannot have a country
if there's no borders it quite literally
so we've actually talked about the
definition of a country versus a nation
and
um I think a country requires Sovereign
borders that determine its jurisdiction
or something to that effect and a nation
is a reference to culture and people I
can't but look we've got people pouring
across the border to the point where uh
we we can't track them there's drug
smuggling there was just in Arizona on
the southern border a man shot an
illegal immigrant they charged him with
first degree murder so we have people
entering this country we have children
dying in the desert and in rivers
because it's an extremely dangerous trip
that's being encouraged effectively by
the bite Administration and by various
ngos and then you have various parts of
the country saying let them vote and
they're expanding that to me it's like
hey what's going on man hey Byron Byron
Donald's we're missing a couple mics
here so I'm going to switch you spots
here in a second yeah we'll have you
jump over a second but uh just to wrap
this this thought up before we yeah Jump
Around yep
that that that is the most immediate
leak that people are entering this
country illegally that Democrats are
calling for amnesty and for the right to
vote the end result of that is clear
there won't be a country correct and
that's what they want they want to
dismantle the system they want to create
chaos they want the system to fail
because they hate the system uh they
hate everything that our country was
founded on and they want to start over
so I mean this is no surprise uh that
they're wanting everything to be
different it's going to take eight to
ten years just to process the people who
came into our country illegally last
year what about the ones who are coming
into our country this year so all of
this is to com to create chaos to
dismantle the system and you know I
could call their policies a failure but
truly they're a success because this is
their intent yeah I think
um the lib what's happening is the chaos
that they're trying to sew is
essentially the end of the liberal
economic order after World War II the
British and the French and the Americans
were like 1949 we're going to build this
Empire to prevent World War III so they
did it now 70 years later that order is
fading in the New Order the world the
liberal the New World Order they call it
is forming and so in order to form this
order they need to create chaos to
create the order out of but I think
there's a lot of useful idiots that are
being swept up and like yeah toxic
compassion we need to help everybody
right like like I don't think Cortez I
don't get the vibe that she's like
orchestrating the downfall of America I
just think that she really cares about
people and like that can take you to
Dark Places if you I'm I'm not convinced
that um many of these Democrats actually
care about people and I know it's just
it's so cliche and tribalistic to say to
be sitting here with a Republican and
we're like oh Democrats are bad but man
it's just so weird to see someone like
AOC uh let's let's just be uh I I hate
being
um
I hate giving the benefit of the doubt
when she says the Boston Children's
Hospital lives of tick tock yoel Roth
says unfortunately Libs of tick tock is
still there and it's just like we we
have so much evidence let's let's let's
let's back away from that the hunter
Biden laptop yeah emails between Joe and
Hunter uh or I'm sorry not not between
Joan Hunter but emails between Hunter
Biden and his associates yeah emails to
uh Hunter Biden talking about sending a
meeting with his dad Tony bobulinski 10
for the big guy private Equity deals
with China flying on Air Force two the
barisma deals I mean like I can cite so
many different stories right factually
proven that Joe Biden was doing these
things
and then when you talk to Democrats they
just either don't know don't care don't
believe you yes so to wrap it all
together
I'm I'm a bit pessimistic in can we
inform people and get the right vote
when we have two things going on one
these people you look at what Adam
Schiff did with the whole Russia gate
stuff with releasing private phone
records I mean some real dark and evil
stuff lies manipulations impeachments
When Donald Trump I believe stumbled
upon the Ukraine Gate scandal with Joe
Biden and the billion dollars and firing
the prosecutor they immediately blamed
him for what Joe Biden did and then
impeached him and impeached him for it
for Joe Biden's crime yeah exactly when
you have that
and then you have Universal mail-in
ballots and ballot harvesting yeah I
gotta say I hate Colorado I hate right I
I'm I'm not so optimistic on I suppose
Republicans could launch a massive bout
harvesting campaign and if that's the
case then I'm not sure standing up and
educating people matters as much as just
knocking on their door and saying fill
it out right yes so I you know in
Colorado uh you know we're trying to get
those ballot harvesting uh campaigns in
in place we have to play by their game
it's legal in Colorado and we're not
doing it because we're not for it but
they're doing that and they're winning
the elections Colorado is turning Bluer
and Bluer we just lost our our
gubernatorial race by 20 points I I mean
this is absurd
um my my District's always been very
conservative and you know won by 546
votes uh so we have to start playing by
their games but you know I agree with
you I'm very much more pessimistic and I
don't think that they care about people
I think they care about power and
winning and and having control and one
of the thing things that they love the
most is controlling people that's very
obvious I can't relate to it man you
know I I can't relate to they just want
to win for the sake of winning I don't
know what they see in the future you
know I I think about traditional family
values as as somebody who's again from a
very liberal area where there's no
Republicans at all Chicago has been run
by democrats for 100 years or whatever
and I think about you know why do we
want traditional Family Values well we
want humans to succeed we want humans to
thrive we want humans to be happier we
want them to be better off we want to
find ways to make life better for
everybody but it seems like the policy
positions that they put forward do the
opposite you I I talk often about why it
is that in big cities typically they're
run by democrats typically crime is
through the roof right and then we we
literally watch throughout the past
several years crime getting worse in
these cities as they release more
criminals now you've got there was this
viral video out of New York where it
wasn't a viral video it was a viral
story where a meteorologist was
mercilessly beaten by teenagers and the
city said we will not criminally charge
these teenagers and I'm just like
are they trying to destroy or do they
just not care and they're extracting as
much as they can as the whole thing
crumbles I think it's all of it yeah I I
do I I they want to be in power they
want to run things their way and they
know they have to completely blow it up
to to be able to reconstruct whatever it
is that they're seeing their Utopia as
but their Utopia isn't going to work
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time